do you think you're intense do you think
of what is it that gives you intensity
is it like a confidence type of thing I
think it's the opposite I'm pretty
anxious socially which I think a lot of
people think that maybe I'm a [ __ ] cuz
I'm kind of quiet in social situations
and they think I'm like judgy or
something like I've had a lot of comics
actually like Sarah Tiana like we didn't
really talk for the first couple years
when I was at The Comedy Store and she's
like I thought you were such a [ __ ]
yeah no I was just like scared and I'm
kind of socially awkward and so I just
keep to myself and it like seems like
aloof and like I think I'm better than
people yeah and I'm really just like
cripplingly nervous and social situation
Wow yeah it's not really my yeah cuz
that's what I thought I was like man
this is she's so like she's a [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] getting [ __ ] done like
you always thought I was a [ __ ] really
I thought you were kind of [ __ ] yeah
really like [ __ ] like how I got allies
a-level but I thought that you were like
oh a couple back from there you know oh
okay I like but you and I have known
each other for a very long time right
but not well though like we've never
like been I feel like we were cool like
because we used to do like bars together
yeah like Westwood bruco if you guys
aren't in LA it's a place on the UCLA
campus that they have a basically a room
that looks like Anne Frank's attic right
next to a karaoke bar
you're screaming over like wow thing
it's awful yeah and then people like
yeah you can hear like the Gestapo and
then you just you're like crying like
college girls like fighting with her
boyfriend yeah but I feel a lot of
Jewish girls crying too because there's
a lot of Jewish girls in that area yeah
so it's really full circle there I feel
like you and I were at least like hang
out and wait for like six hours to go up
that's truly like you know five minutes
in front of for drunk people and maybe I
was intimidated maybe I was just like
kind of like I think I'm more of like an
intimidated kind of time in my life
probably just like it was maybe afraid
to talk to girls as much as socialize or
be on a comfortable level so in my head
I had like this other idea and I was
scared of everybody too because I think
I was insecure about I mean this was it
there weren't that many female comics
like when I started like now there's
like a ton felt like I was like you
Barry so bold to new die yeah Phyllis
Diller know that we're only yeah there
weren't that there weren't as many so I
think I thought in order to be respected
by the guys I had to like kind of be
tougher or something or like I never
wanted to get the reputation for
flirting with comics or dating comma I
think I would be like a little more
loose you know because at that time I
was just such a you know like did you
feel like a commodity there like in a
way like and I just mean it like this
you feel like a commodity like in the
sense that okay here's an attractive
could will agree that you're attractive
we agree with that back that it might
have been an eight point for less fee
for the stress that before the court is
all gotten to I mean he would have to
come back in time and ask people back
then but I mean so yeah a strong a funny
confident attractive lady I wasn't
confident I think I came off him off is
gone but I definitely wasn't confident
me how can we not trade my dad confident
but like I feel like I was confident but
I don't really it I was a perception it
was like armor you were focused though I
was definitely focused cuz I want to be
good and that was the thing that I think
was seemed as intimidating like I would
see you like I remember like talking
like Jeff Ross and stuff and I'm like oh
man no no bad way I was writing on the
road yeah so maybe and maybe people just
didn't know that I was writing on the
road so I kind of knew him a little
right but you know it's interesting like
yeah people thought I was like you know
super funny ones I was like she works so
hard but it was back then like you had
to work twice as hard to get a spot as a
girl and like I felt all this pressure
that like because there were so few
female comics that like I have to be
funny cuz there's already this
reputation that women are funny right so
like I want to nail it for like all
women yeah you know like I had I put so
much is now ridiculous so Oksana Baiul I
thought about you'll have a branded like
no I think was she a gymnast is she
known for her she's a gymnast I think
she'll and did it don't people didn't
think she was gonna and she just stuck
like you know but I feel like FEMA ice
skaters that are in the Olympics are
known for being good at ice skater okay
I'm something of Jumna sim with some ice
skating but off the ice
what does that call gymnastics
gymnastics yeah yeah and yeah who's
somebody they just landed one one time
and they just like that's what I'm
picturing you just and then like you
know like it cuz there was when I
started it was like when a girl will go
on stage that was like everyone's cue to
go to the bathroom right I used to good
they'd be like in the way that you got
brought up by then back then as a woman
people will be like
so are you ready for a lady are you
ready for a female comedian and everyone
will just you just feel like rustling
and just get up and I would die like
refund like everyone's just trying their
money back so I felt so much pressure to
be good and I think for me like you see
I'm being too intense I'm on Tylenol PM
I'm being there um but I thought a you
know back then like I also really want a
comics to respect me because I think
there was this sort of stigma that I
carried that because I had done like a
couple like vh1 shows and stuff where
people thought that I got too much too
fast oh how I didn't remember any of
that I really didn't want comics to hate
me or think I was getting anything I
didn't deserve because like comedy clubs
that's our home like walking into a
comedy club and having people comics not
like you that's like your worst
nightmare so I just really wanted to
like earn everything I got because I do
think there was also you know there is
pressure always on comedy clubs do like
we have to put a woman on the lineup and
they never wanted people to think I was
getting anything I was getting because I
was a girl and I didn't want to get
anything just cuz I was a girl but at
the same time you want to get you see
they had this like low-key high key kind
of chip inside you that was like you
know I want to be like a Amelia Earhart
in a way not dot but not disappeared to
the other but like you know no but she's
a dude imagine this okay first of all is
some women couldn't even drive that well
okay imagine getting into a plane and if
I can take it off and say you're going
around the world oh I don't know what
the bets were in Vegas but every bet was
on her not [ __ ] coming back didn't
come back she didn't but still so brave
to like yeah you low-key have like a
little bit of Amelia Earhart iki you
said like you wanted to kind of you know
I mean you had but you were you seem
like you always have had
some laser focus because I feel like you
just came in like this lightning bolt
and the next thing you know like you
definitely seem like you're always
working hard thank you I appreciate that
I hope so no doubt I grew up poor I know
a lot of like I didn't have any other
option right I didn't have a back-up
plan and I realized very early on that I
have very few skills I have a very
specific set of skills totally amazing
and see that's what town'll p.m. done
I'm Liam Neeson like I'm just messing up
like words I don't say a lot well no
worries keep doing this in a little bit
we're gonna do in aziz ansari act out in
case like we're at the same place and
you get the rest you know and she's
smarter than being 22 is like it's the
time of age but no we all we will do a
thing in a little bit where when this
town of him sets in more we're how a man
should behave around intoxicated wants
to read I almost said incarcerated I
it's starting to kick it it makes me
again that one of those right because
the intoxicated role play and the
incarcerated role play a very different
role different orifices yeah totally
different totally different posture
different core engagement level ya know
I didn't have any other options and like
I tried to do a couple other things like
I tried to bartend I tried to be
someone's assistant and I just realized
very quickly like I am just not good at
anything else so I was like I don't
succeed at this like I don't have a
back-up plan because you astronauts
right for me really no I just can't do
that cuz yeah you just seem like an
astronaut and then you kind of went you
know no me I mean I was doing the Comedy
Store open mic for like four years
showing up at five o'clock waiting for
hours to eat ship for three minutes I
mean funny when people like she like
came out of nowhere I'm like really I
was doing rooster T feathers in bowling
alleys for five years I guess I didn't
know that I guess I didn't know that
really yes and this is my procession my
presentment it's just my little
perception you know but yeah to me you
just always seem like yeah just like a
like uh like laser focused you know and
but I always admired it I mean I if
anything else like though I'm gonna you
know I mean I feel like also but as a
girl like going to comedy clubs like I'm
not gonna go [ __ ] a bunch of dudes after
you know okay so the how about this do
didn't you get out what else made it
right right yeah well that's the thing
it always seemed like you were there for
the work that's what it stabilized
because like there's nothing for a
female comedian in a comedy club after
10:30 when you're done woman now it
seems different cuz now you it's like
you have all these like it feels like
there's a lot of girls who like I get
texts a lot and it's like can I open for
you can I do this and those kind of
things are fun and I want to have
Malcolm X you mean right but sometimes
it's a bit more than that you know which
is like what do you mean but are like
here's what I'll say I think can I open
for you then open for you like I feel
like sometimes there's that vibe there
you know and sometimes it's even a
little bit more poignant than that right
but did you did you feel like guys
treated you different though as you were
never as guys will always be a little
bit no matter what if the girl walks up
you know and she's like dying of thirst
in the desert and she's like can I have
some water and you're like party's gonna
be like can I give it to you out of my
day you know like that's always gonna
come as half but no but I mean not come
but just if you could get real water out
of your day okay but it's like men are
always gonna want yeah or there's always
a little bit of that yeah yeah maybe I
think if you were the one of the few
women around then it would be wow I was
really scared of getting a reputation I
would like hang out with are open for
Bobby Lee or something on the rope he
would sue [ __ ] Bobby Lee and rice
whoa like so I think I just want to
really distance myself from any
opportunity that people could just
assume I was sleeping with comics I've
never dated a comic write ever you know
and then I did the Rose what about Delia
though every day never dated probably
yes huh
did he say no how weird is it though
that I feel like you and Krista starting
to look like the same person you have
way nicer skin but it's like to think I
have a better hairline and less facial
yeah buddy just something's going on
yeah and it could be the lighting in
here I do I do think that um one time
I'll p.m. and I'll think I'm Chris
D'Elia so I'm close as well I get that a
little bit I can see that I think it's
also the confident cuz it's like a
narcissistic for me some of us is the
confidence to both you guys think I'm
confident that's so funny Chris to me is
the most confident human plant I can't
wrap my head around that I'm in therapy
at a 12-step program to get his inner
model and I'm not him
clothes I've got like two lines but I
don't yeah I yeah I'm really insecure
and maybe just when I'm quiet I seem
like I'm like have it together or people
are projecting right you always think
that people have it more together than
they really do right yes and I pretend
to have it together on Instagram we all
like project this life that we don't
even have yeah you know why am I telling
you this
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one